Now this pseudocode that you're looking at, is very similar
to the pseudocode for verifying your credit card number. The
pseudocode for verifying your credit card starts by setting n
and sum, and it also sets a count. Then for each
digit, again starting from the right, it increments the count,
and then uses the count to determine what to do with
the digit. If the count is odd, then the digit
gets added to the sum. Otherwise, if the count is even,
then it matters how big the digit is. If the
digit is less than five, then we add two times the
digit to the sum. Otherwise, if the count is even and
the digit is five or greater, then we add two times
the digit to the sum, and subtract nine. And then,
if the last digit of the sum is zero, the card
number is valid. How would you write Java code for this?
There's a lot going on here, so first let's do one
part of it. How would you change the code for summing all of the digits, so that
it only sums every other digit, starting with the rightmost? I'd like you to
complete the sum certain digits method, which given a number like,
12,345 would return 5 plus 3 plus 1. And for a number
like 6,789, would return 9 plus 7. I'll give
you the code for summing all the digits to start with. And there will be
some hint links above the submit button, to
hint videos in case you'd like a boost.